- I was 12 years old when
I first got trafficked.
(somber music)
My home life was very violent.
Because of the things that
I'd been trough in my life,
being sexually molested at a young age,
having a family member not
believe me when I told them
that it happened by the
hands of a family member,
I felt that no one was there to protect me
and no one cared or loved me.
When I was 12 years old
I was a runaway.
I was just walking around in the streets
and a guy pulled up on the side of me
and asked me if I was okay.
I told him I was fine and
I started to walk away
and it started to rain.
And he was like, "Just
come sit in the car with me
"until the rain stops."
I was cold and wet so I agreed.
I was basically kidnapped and um,
raped and beaten, sold for days.
So from that moment on, I
just stayed in the streets.
I couldn't imagine myself
getting out of that situation.
I felt worthless.
I had little to no self esteem.
I would literally work
early in the morning
and I would see kids
my age going to school
and it was hard for me
to look at those kids
because there was a lot of shame.
The one way that I was able
to get a break from the life
was to basically go into a store
and steal in plain sight while my pimp
was outside in the car.
If I was caught stealing, I
would eventually get arrested
and I would go to juvenile hall.
For most girls or most kids
they will see it as a punishment,
but it was structure in my life.
It was a safe place and I knew that
no one will be able to harm me.
My life basically changed
once I was beaten by my pimp.
And I was in a hospital
for a short stint of time
and I knew that this was my way out.
I was turning 18 and there
was no more safety net,
so if I was to get in trouble,
if I was to steal to get away from a pimp,
I was going to the county
and that was a whole 'nother world that I
did not want to be a part of.
So, I took that opportunity
to leave California
in hopes of leaving the life.
I realized that I was a victim
and then I became a survivor.
And now, I am a warrior.
(uplifting music)
(sighs)
what I would tell
a 12 year old me.
I would tell the 12 year old me that
it's going to get better.
I will tell her that,
"Your life may seem like it's
being sacrificed right now,
"but it's going to help
so many other women,
"so just keep on going."